the number one mistake that people are
making in life today and it's and it's
just so unbelievably obvious is they're
living life in the middle you know 99.9%
of the people that watch or listen to
this content are living in the middle
there they're hedging and making excuses
and justifying why they are not 100%
happy it's because like every other
person out there besides a few select
people they are living in this middle
ground and I just say the middle and
when I think about how you win in
business and entrepreneurship the most
of all in life it's by understanding the
macro and micro opportunities and
executions if you really understand how
to break through how to be in that zone
how to really really really
win the game it comes down to a strategy
that looks like this are you balancing
your ego with your humility are you
balancing your ego with your humility do
equally think that you're the greatest
of all time and you can do it and that
also you're a piece of sh and nobody
cares when you're gone I like reading my
negative comments way more than my
positive ones I mean it I mean it and I
don't think there are trolls and haters
I really don't I think that they've
consumed me in a context and I need to
be thoughtful about what they're
thinking now I do believe I equally
believe that if you're taking time to
consume people's other people's content
on the internet and then you have the
energy to leave terrible comments you're
cut you're in a sad place yourself you
know so usually when I read like Gary
Vee you're a snake oil salesman my first
default is okay why did they interpret
this content this way but even before I
go there my alpha even before that my
first default is like I feel bad for
that person I tell everybody that I meet
along the way that I think is authentic
put your two fingers in your ears
execute in perpetuity and let the chips
fall that's the only way you'll ever be
able to achieve something from
markable because when you were doing
anything interesting or game-changing or
like different
you're only gonna I've only been booed
my whole life every single thing I've
done basically from school to
professionally I mean I took I don't
know if I've ever taken more heat for
not opening a second liquor store with
my dad like the entire liquor industry
which was my life right my dad's liquor
industry in New Jersey was my life every
one of those people ridiculed the bad of
me for selling liquor on the computer
you're pouring all that money and
selling liquor and the computer you
should open a second liquor store right
so like I think there's certain people
ponch honora's givers politicians
there's millions of people different
kinds of teachers there's certain people
were just capable of doing that and I
think the reason I talk a lot about it
is my hope is if this one answer can let
them hear one less voice that's moving
the needle because you're either on
offense or you're on defense and
dwelling about other people's opinions
of how you live your life is defense I
don't think most people are actually
judging themselves either I think
they're taking the voices of others to
allow themselves to be judged people
like Gary I hear you but what if you're
you know they're like I get it don't
listen to others but what if your own
voice the one in your own head is
telling you you suck or distend the
other thing I'm like you've taken on the
voice of someone else I really believe
that
and for some reason through self-esteem
serendipity and many other things very I
mean I consciously in third grade
decided to not try in school not because
I was a normal third grader because I
definitely wasn't it was because I was
like this has nothing to do with my life
and I'm gonna start working on my actual
scale and I'm willing to deal with the
judgment of my teachers you know I'm not
fun it is to grow up your whole life and
have your all your friends parents think
you're a loser because the only
framework in society at that time is
your school grades do you know how many
people here literally drive cars to
impress people and
hate people literally going in debt or
getting further from leaving the job
they don't like to do something I'll
make them happy because they have to buy
a certain car that has a logo that
impresses people that they despise do
you understand how up that is do you
nobody people here live in homes where
they don't use more than half the rooms
in the house like we are so
fundamentally in a vortex that makes no
sense that I am unbelievably passionate
understanding how much money you make
and what you can do to get off of it but
the problem is again people are doing so
many things to keep up with the Joneses
to make it look like they're successful
to appease their parents and a million
other things that have nothing to do
with themselves and we need to change
that game I love when people like Gary
Vee like the comments are just so fun
Gary Vee like you suck bro you repeat
the same I'm like cuz it's right face
the reason I keep repeating it the
reason I believe in it is because I know
for so many of you even though you've
seen it 87 times this moment in real
life but this time might be the time it
happens that's how it actually works
this is a game of perspective even you
understand what's happening or not you
know many people have defaulted into
thinking this is a terrible time my
friends this is the greatest time to be
a human being in the history of Earth I
mean I don't know what else to tell you
this is like math this is not my opinion
this is what's going on with genocide
and health life expenses like this is
the best like for all the we have with
racism and sexism and a lot of terror we
got plenty
meanwhile they had the Black Plague
meanwhile they had World War two
meanwhile they had real and we sit
around and complain about the dumbest in
the world people complain about like
getting the wrong milk in their coffee
from a barista or that you're what this
is my your Wi-Fi is a little slower than
normal like you're upset you can feel
the speed is a little lower or or my or
you got a few less likes then you're
usually getting on a public the stuff
that we actually spend time on is
fascinating to me it is a complete and
utter lack of perspective from 2007 to
2011 when nobody knew who the guy was
and Twitter was the platform of the day
I spent every day replying to every
single tweet that made a mention of me
and used to go to sleep at 3 and 4
o'clock in the morning until I
completely got to everybody and that's
how I built my foundation people want
the glitz and the glamour and the caviar
but they're not willing to eat this
period if I mean if you don't understand
how this actually plays out there is no
shortcut
there's no hack there's no tip there's
just the work I'm obsessed with
perspective like I genuinely believe you
find what you're looking for if you are
looking for bad right now it's a piece
of cake if you're looking for good right
now it's a piece of cake I'm just asking
you what are you looking for like please
just a very simple question like and by
the way I I hate in a lot of ways I hate
the way I talk because it's super simple
and I'm sitting right now thinking about
the kid who's listening to this and she
or he is in her room right now earpods
in listening to this and they're
miserable because their dad's an
alcoholic or their moms they're like
real you know like tough stuff and
they're like ah it's so slick you it's
not that simple yet it is like you know
one thing I don't do well is talk about
my problems
it which manifests in many ways it
manifests in being taken for granted in
my real life and in my collective life
by outward life I have problems lots of
problems real ones I grew up with lots
of this stuff like lots and lots of lots
of stuff I just am not capable of going
into it like I don't I don't get going
like I can't get there and so one of the
things that I you know that I try to
remind kids and like take me out of the
equation like don't even use me when I'm
saying these things Sabrina if you know
of one person that has ever gotten to a
happy place that dealt with your
circumstance there is a blueprint the
end there have been people nitrene Lane
legendary football player was thrown in
a dumpster the second he was born went
on to be one of the great football
players of all time
dated every actress in the game was red
foxes bodyguard iconic gentleman
dumpster like like there's all sorts of
circumstances
tell us about failure and why it's
important to love it yeah cuz you I love
it I like micro failure
I like micro failure I hate macro
failure like death of your business is
bad but but to me you know what's funny
I'll use a boxing analogy my favourite
boxing but i watch a lot of boxing
I think boxing is a very interesting and
I know and I'm super into mixed martial
arts but I grew up on boxing I
understand it better and I like watching
it because there's so many things that
happen in boxing first of all what I
love about boxing is there's nowhere to
hide you know like it's super
interesting right there's nowhere to
hide number two there's something
there's a scenario boxing that I love
the most
there's for some reason there's nothing
more interesting to me than watching
somebody get knocked down in the first
round and then go on to win the fight
easily it's an interesting psyche right
and I like that and this is what I'm
thinking about it which is like here's
what's bad in boxing and in business
going into a fight getting knocked the
[ __ ] out in the first round and losing
the match bad getting knocked down and
then having the adversity to readjust to
what you got caught on and navigating it
to ease
when a fight is remarkable that's how I
think about entrepreneurship people the
reason so many people struggle with
entrepreneurship is you have micro
failures almost daily and they're very
in-your-face you can't hide and I like
that I like failure I because I think I
deserve it
I hate when people don't respect the
game when I fail it means I've up and I
like that because I think people get
audacious my number one thing that I
hate about capitalism is that people use
it and they love it and they're big
capitalists and they love open market
and competition and all that and then
they become 73 and they try to use all
their money to protect their money
they're not willing to let a young lion
eat them the way they ate somebody else
I hate when they try to manipulate it
that's what I love about sports what I
love about sports is when you're 36 and
you were once the best player in the
league but now you're getting a little
bit older and your body breaks down you
are forced to retire the one thing that
entrepreneurship and capitalism has to
adjust to is once you get old and you're
tired and you want to be on a yacht
instead of working yours you should
leave some money because you're losing
the number one thing you need to do is
deploy self awareness about yourself and
how you want to communicate and what you
want to communicate the reality of
trying to be successful is super
fascinating everybody has the ambition
or thought process of living a 1% life
but the far majority have no interest in
putting in the work ethic of the 1% that
is required for that life and that's
fine you know another thing that's a
complete contradiction is how many
people I know that are far happier when
their business the amount of people I've
really looked at a lot of businesses at
this point you know hundreds of
thousands probably over the last 20
years because of my investing career
there are so many people that have a
business that makes them two hundred
thousand a year they want to grow and
then when it goes to 280,000 they went
from extremely happy to miserable on
that small of a Delta you know please
please
is in a success world please understand
that success is happiness not net
dollars in I literally replied to I have
a ridiculously funny post on Instagram
right now right let my last post about
me garage saleing and a lot of the
comments were like literally things like
I don't get it
why is somebody who's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars going out there and
buying things for a dollar and selling
it for fifteen bucks and I literally am
in there like on the road here like
replying to some of you when I'm gonna
be on stage and replying an Instagram to
kids that are asking me that I'm
replying happiness i Gary as a human get
dramatically happier when I go to a
garage sale and buy something worth
twenty bucks for a dollar and get the
high of discovering it and knowing that
I'm gonna pay a dollar and sell it for
twenty then I do when I land a seven
million dollar deal for vaynermedia and
by the way there's no comparison that's
just who I am I think the biggest
vulnerability you've got is you actually
value somebody's opinion more than you
value your own if the reason I've been
able to always do my thing is when I was
24 and people were like oh you work at
your dad's liquor store like I heard
that as like a chip on my shoulder you
know I loved it I was like cool keep
sleeping on me you know like I'm glad
you're on Wall Street making a hundred
thousand buying BMWs and dumb jewelry
I'll see you in 30 years you understand
like to me the way you win is you
realize you can't hear nobody not your
parents I mean listen you gotta listen
to coach and all that I get it but at
the end of the day my guy yourself you
got to get real real quiet up here I
can't hear anything you go look at my
Instagram right now my first post I'll
post something first 100 replies in one
second you're Jesus you walk on water
you're the best you're the all-time
can't hear him the next hundred you're a
piece of your foolish you're a snake oil
salesman can't hear him I'm in my own
mind doing my own thing and that comes
with self-esteem everybody's trying to
keep up with the Joneses
I'm not worried about you being on the
in the Hamptons on a blow-up Swan
I'm not worried about you renting out
cash from the bank and putting it to
your ear
I'm not worried you jumped a fence and
took a photo in front of a private plane
what do you think these people are doing
they're posing patients long game you
know what's amazing about being an
entrepreneur we get to play forever
right
I'm gonna be working when I'm 96 trying
to find my next hustle I was at the top
of the wine game and I left because I've
won I didn't want to do it anymore and
went into marketing where everyone liked
the first article written about me was
like this guy huh
why in Twitter I think the article in
the big advertising magazine was Twitter
boy is what they called me Twitter boy
thinks he's gonna come and win Madison
Avenue ha ha ha ha ha they're not
laughing anymore you know and even this
game now I can already feel it I'm like
oh man three four or five years from now
this thing's a wrap I'm gonna be the guy
so I'm gonna have to start selling
oranges or something you know I gotta
figure you know I've been up to figure
something out because I lose like I'm
about to climb back to sports I grew up
a die-hard Yankees Jets Rangers Knicks
fan the Yankees and Rangers won their
championships I literally stopped
watching them Knicks and jets are gonna
take me a minute you know but like but
like I'm just about the color I just
love to climb like even like back to
sports does that I think it's great
analogy I'll turn on a random game I
need to know who the underdog is that's
my team I'm just about to climb you know
like to me when I see a kid wearing a
Steph Curry Jersey and that kid lives in
New York I think that gets solved
I mean it he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
I think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own City nothing is more exciting than
selling something you believe in this
the second you get paid a million
dollars under the table to even sell the
glue that's when your but if you're
actually selling something you actually
believe in you'll win my biggest problem
with people is they sell something they
don't believe in they just it's the
thing that they've stumbled into it's
the thing that they just think they'll
make the most money on that's the thing
that makes the most vulnerable super
long term if you love it and you believe
in it there's a lot of things I could be
selling that would make me a lot more
money you know some people when I do
track like I do things I want to be
doing like I love showing people how to
make that have 20 bucks how to like
start living their life with more money
that's why I do trash talk there's
literally people that leave comments
like Gary Vee this is not going to help
you buy the Jets no I understand that
eight hours of my time is not making
three hundred nine dollars is not
necessarily the mathematical equation to
get to the Jets but is it because if I
helped 40 million people live a much
better life if I'm 200 million dollars
short when the time comes
can i crowd fund the last part I think
so outside of spending time with my
inner juice family and closest friends
and outside a garage selling and
watching the Jets there's nothing I'd
rather do than work a 15-hour day
yourself where you know you and I always
have this why I shoveled snow and did
lemonade and I washed cars as a
seven-year-old all day long on August
9th
cuz it's what I like and I'm not gonna
judge somebody who wants to look 9 to 5
beyond 13 softball teams and play video
games all day and make 42k year if she
and he are pumped as they're equal to me
because I know a bunch of miserable
billionaires and I know a lot of happy
55 ka years and everything in between
you so you talk patience to write that
people should be patient in in the
pursuit of their goals at what point
does patient just become
illusion a lot of times oh so what are
the hacks or the tips that you for them
to be self-aware to know when to just
why don't when is patience just right
we're having the same thing for seven
years and nothing good has happened
you're delusional
let's start there that's a test I
believe in that if there's been no
progress in your rap career or in your
art or your video blog and you've been
doing it every day for seven years as
hard as you can and nothing has happened
the market has spoken that's one way now
is that four years is that two years do
people jump off like you need to see
some level of progress to keep you
having blood in the water to get you
going but sometimes there is a
breakthrough because if the machine is
in between you and the market well then
you got to be discovered but the reason
now I think it's more pure is because
SoundCloud and Spotify and YouTube and
Shopify and the Amazon now you get the
feedback loop so fast and it isn't the
arbitrary subjective call of the reason
that took some of the greatest stars of
all time
eleven years to break through is because
other people had say people didn't see
Gaga's talent they shook thought she was
weird somebody thought she wasn't weird
she breaks out AG Lady gaga today she
goes on YouTube and Spotify direct and
the market speaks quicker people are
more famous quicker now if they have the
talent
cuz nobody's in the middle this is why I
talk in general terms on content of
course because I don't have the context
but if somebody sat here and I listened
for 40 minutes I would tell them if
they're delusional or just impatient and
most people are impatient and delusional
if you liked this video and want to see
more like it let me know down the
comments below or if you hate it and
never want to see it again same thing
let me know in the comments below if you
want some music to improve your
productivity check out my music channel
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe